[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous je suis
ravi de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
émission j'espère que vous allez bien
nous sommes le mardi 3 octobre voici le
programme de ce soir sans eux impossible
d'envoyer un mail ou de se connecter à
une application les Data Center sont
essentiels pour faire fonctionner nos
ordinateurs ou nos téléphones hier un
nouveau centre de données a été inauguré
à manie leamo le ministre délégué en
charge du numérique Jean-Noël barreot
était sur place nous aussi ils étaient 1
à venir voir s'entraîner les joueurs de
l'équipe de rugby du P de Gal au stade
de Porsche fontaine à Versailles la
ville accueille la sélection durant la
Coupe du monde de rugby certains en ont
profité pour demander des autographe et
pour échanger avec leur idole nous
parlerons également de rap ce soir dans
votre 78 à après Marseille et le 93
c'est au tour des Yvelines de créer leur
propre compilation parmi la cinquantaine
d'artistes présents on retrouve
notamment La Fouine Bosch ou encore 47
terres leur objectif montrer leur
appartenance au territoire et porter un
message d'apaisement entre les quartiers
et puis l'invité du 78 en 2è partie
d'émission avec John colémalé le maire
adjoint délégué à la communication de
Buc ce weekend la bande dessinée est à
l'honneur pour la 30e année au château
de Buc une 50 d'auteur est attendue
venant de Belgique d'Italie ou encore
des serbies au programme dédicace
animation et exposition mais tout de
suite on prend la direction de Man Lamo
je vous le disais en début de cette
émission hier Jean-Noël Barau le
ministre délégué en charge du numérique
inauguré un nouveau data center ce
nouveau centre de données se veut
écesponsable le reportage de Régine
ralch avec une surface de plus de 10000
M carré ce data center s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la souveraineté européenne
télé house l'a inauguré à Manil etamoo
ce lundi 2 octobre en présence du
ministre de la transition numérique et
des télécommunications nous avons là un
centre de données qui va être destiné en
priorité aux acteurs souverains à des
dasso systè à des Talès qui sont
géographiquement assez proches d'ici
puis nous avons un territoire qui est
très numérique et très fortement marqué
par la souveraineté numérique F végétal
absence de gaz frigorigène le data
center se veut écoresponsable en mettant
en place des actions concrètes pour
réduire ses émissions de gaz quand on
émet du CO2 c'est notre responsabilité
de tendre vers le réduire et c'est le
cas pour les Data Center qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie qui consomment
beaucoup d'électricité donc notre
responsabilité c'est de prendre ce sujet
à bras le corp et mettre des actions
concrètes qui permettent d'arriver à 0
CO2 pour cette activité parce que
l'essence même du numérique c'est
décarboner l'économie c'estàd de réduire
les flux physiques qu'il y a sur terre
et de les passer sur le numérique qui
devient décarboné donc donc pour faire
ça on a on a une obligation et on essaie
de remplir cette obligation en voulant
contribuer à un avenir plus durable
téléh s'engage à atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2026 allezleur à présent
de faire le point sur les informations à
retenir dans les ivelines avec Gabriel
Gontier et on commence ces informations
Gabriel par une inauguration qui avait
lieu ce matin au Ménil Leroi en présence
de Valérie PCR oui Mathilde après un an
de travaux l'heure était à
l'inauguration de la première tranche de
la nouvelle voie verte pour l'occasion
la Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
s'est rendu sur place comprenant des
pontons des zones de protection
écologique ou encore des parcours
sportifs cette voie va permettre aux
famille et aux personnes à mobilité
réduite de profiter à nouveau d'éberg et
de développer l'usage du vélo on écoute
les propos recueillis par Patrick
Jacques de dixmud on sait que c'est une
grande demande de nos concitoyens de
toujours développer des amén n agement
des pistes cyclables pour pouvoir
pratiquer le vélo que ce soit pour aller
au travail ou pour le plaisir en famille
et donc là on a un magnifique projet qui
permet à la fois de profiter de la
nature en bord de scène et aussi de se
déplacer à vélo et la deuxième phase des
travaux Mathilde concernera le
raccordement des pistes cyclables en
bord de scène des communes du PEC et de
maison la fite à Mantel jolie maintenant
un lycée a été visé ce matin par un tir
de mortier d'artifice oui il s'agit du
lycée Jean Rostan et ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il est pris pour cible
ce matin peu avant 9h un individu
cagoulet avisé le personnel de
l'établissement notamment la proviseur
adjointe avec un tir de mortier un élève
a été légèrement blessé au molet une
enquête a été ouverte et l'individu est
recherché en réaction les professeurs du
lycée ont exercé leur droit de retrait
les élèves eux n'ont pas eu cours cet
après-midi les salariés de Kolis
viennent d'entamer une 4e semaine de
grève oui la mobilisation ne faiblit pas
sur le site de Montesson mobilisé depuis
4 semaines les grévistes de l'opérateur
de transport public demande une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail et le rétablissement de leur
prime supprimé ce matin le député
insoumis des Yvelines William Martinet a
apporté son soutien au grevistes en se
rendant sur place un mot de sport
maintenant avec le retour de la Transat
Jacques Vabre oui la présentation de la
16e édition de cette course
transatlantique en duo s'est déroulé cet
après-midi à Paris alors parmi les 200
participants de ivelinois Louis Burton
originaire de la selle Lesbordes près de
Rambouillet partira sur bureauvallé de
son côté le versaillais Éric Bellon
s'élancera sur son nouveau bateau
standas one départ de la course le 29
octobre depuis Le Havre pour rejoindre
la Martinique et on termine ces
informations avec la 5e édition de la
Nuit du droit ça aura lieu demain soir
oui tout à fait depuis 2018 cet
événement célèbre le droit sur tout le
territoire chaque 4 octobre alors
l'objectif c'est de célébrer
l'anniversaire de la Constitution et de
mieux la faire connaître aux citoyens en
organisant des rencontres à à Versailles
plusieurs lieux ouvreent leurs portes au
public c'est le cas du tribunal
administratif ou encore du tribunal
judiciaire la Faculté de droit de
l'Université Versailles SaintQuentin à
guyencour participera également à cette
nuit du droit vous pouvez consulter les
lieux et les programmes en détail sur
les le site pardon qui s'affiche en bas
de votre écran et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier et si vous aussi vous
voyez une information ou une image qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 new
[Musique]
un peu de politique à présent ancien
député des ivelines et actuel
vice-président du conseil départemental
Philippe benasaya présente sa
candidature à la présidence de la
fédération du Parti les républicain des
Yvelines il affrontera dans cette
élection Hutman nasrou conseiller
régional et proche de Valéri pcrè
Philippe benasaya explique à Patrice
carmou les raisons de sa candidature
écoutez je lance ma campagne de 5 à
versaill on sera très nombreux il y aura
Gérard arché Pierre Bédier Sophie prima
il y aura beaucoup d'élus beaucoup de
maires beaucoup de tous ceux qui me
soutiennent beaucoup de déléués de
circonscription comme on dit beaucoup de
maires beaucoup de conseillers
départementaux donc ça ça va être ça va
être le le grand moment moi je pars d'un
principe très rapidement même si on en a
déjà parlé que il faut à la fois du
renouvellement comme je l'ai dit mais
aussi de l'expérience voilà j'ai fait
basculer une ville j'ai fait basculer
une circonscription j'ai fait basculer
un canton je pense que cette cette
expérience de terrain est utile pour les
républicains aujourd'hui et puis puis
également il faut aussi ce que j'ai dit
renouveler de font en comble la maison
pas dit qu'elle était en ruine mais elle
elle portait une histoire maintenant je
pense qu'il faut maintenant porter un
avenir et porter cet avenir là
maintenant en matière de communication
en matière de militantisme et en matière
de de contenu aussi avec des thématiques
importantes comme l'environnement que
l'on a tendance de temps en temps à
oublier et vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de cet entretien avec
Philippe benasaya dans l'émission vyp et
nous avons été rejoints en plateau par
John coléalé bon bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes le maire adjoint à la
communication pour la ville de Buc ce
weekend se tient le festival de la BD au
château de Buc est-ce que tout est prêt
écoutez nos équipes au service culturel
en tout cas travaille d'arrache-pied
depuis une année pour préparer cet
anniversaire vous le savez nous fêtons
cette année les 30 ans oui c'est un
rendez-vous important c'est un
rendez-vous extrêmement important ça va
marquer euh d'une pierre blanche ce ce
ce festival pour nous nous nous
attendons à plus de 10000 personnes
après 8000 personnes en 2022 euh nous
attendons à recevoir a priori il va
faire très beau donc nous invitons les
familles les parents à venir en ombre à
ce festival où beaucoup de surprises ont
été préparées on va garder un peu de
suspense je vous propose de dérouler le
programme tout à l'heure en en fin
d'émission avant j'ai envie de vous
demander est-ce que vous suivez la Coupe
du monde de rugby ah bah oui un petit
peu on essaye en tout cas les matchs de
la France on attend celui de vendredi
avec impatience également donc je
souhaite bonne chance à notre équipe et
bien sachez que hier c'était l'événement
à Versailles puisque le public a pu
assister au au deuxè entraînement
collectif de l'équipe du pays de Gal au
stade de Porsche fontaine à Versailles
c'est le reportage de Michel el midoro
et de Louis Douchin pour avoir le
maillot des joueurs et comme ça ça fait
un souvenir un peu c'était la chasse au
maillots et aux autog ce lundi 2 octobre
le pays de Gal a ouvert un de ses
entraînements au public versaillais au
stade de porschefontaine cet après-midi
ils étaient plus de 1000 supporters
autour du terrain bon c'est une bonne
chose qu'il soit là de voir les qui
s'entraînent c'est un plus c'est un plus
pour Versailles et pour le pour le club
de versaill je pense qu'on a une chance
aujourd'hui de pouvoir les voir
s'entraîner et puis de le rendre hommage
et honneur en fait en étant présent
autour du stade après un entraînement
d'un heure le 15 du poireau s'est prêté
un bain de foule auprès du public un
moment de partage qui a duré une dizaine
de
minutes on a bien été accueilli à
Versailles on espère rester plus
longtemps dans le tournoi pour profiter
de ce bel
endroit j'adore la France je sais que la
France est une terre de rugby et les
Français sont de très bons supporters
installé dans la cité royale sur la
pelouse du Rugby Club de Versailles
pendant toute la Coupe du monde du rugby
la ville se félicite de l'engouement
généré par la venue des rugbyman
britanniqu pendant la compétition certes
on a ouvert le 3 septembre mais on a
enfin la récompense de les voir sur site
et surtout de le faire partager à notre
population donc le premier entraînement
ouvert au public de ce vendredi et
aujourd'hui le second voilà on le prend
comme une récompense pour la population
pour les agents qui se sont investis et
sous un magnifique soleil donc on ne
peut-être que ravi prochain match pour
les Gallois ce samedi ils joueront leur
dernier match de poule face à la Georgie
àant les dragons rouges sont pour
l'instant premier et devrait se
qualifier pour les quarts de finale
l'occasion pour le 15 du poireau de
prolonger son séjour à Versailles au
plus grand bonheur des
supporters allez c'est l'heure à présent
de passer à notre page
[Musique]
culture et on commence cette page
culture par un tout nouveau forma chaque
chaque mardi une salle de spectacle du
territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir une pièce un balai ou un
concert aujourd'hui c'est la ferme du
Mané à Montini le Bretonneux qui vous
donne trois raisons d'aller voir trois
cafés gourmands le vendredi 20 octobre
bonjour je m'appelle José Cachin je suis
maire adjoint délégué à la culture et
l'vénementiel à montinil Bretonneux et
si je suis devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
pour vous donner trois bonnes raisons
d'aller assister à au concert de trois
cafés
gourmands
la première raison elle est très simple
euh vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer
l'actualité et vous avez certainement
entendu dire que trois cafés gourmands
allaient se séparer à l'issue de la
tournée 2324 donc j'aurais tendance à
dire que pour les inconditionnels c'est
une occasion supplémentaire de les voir
et c'est peut-être la dernière fois et
pour ceux qui sont qui ne les
connaissent pas encore et ben c'est
l'occasion de les découvrir mais
également peut-être aussi de les voir la
dernière fois la deuxième raison c'est
que c'est un album auquel a collaboré
jean-jaces Goldman tout le monde connaît
Jean-Jacques Goldman bien évidemment et
la pâte qu'il met à chaque fois démontre
ou témoigne en tout cas que c'est un
label de qualité et puis enfin la
troisième raison elle est toute simple
c'est que trois cafés gourmands ça
s'écoute ça se chante et ça se danse
donc c'est une occasion inespérée de
passer une soirée en famille
[Musique]
voilà en quelques mots les trois bonnes
raisons d'aller voir tris cafés gourmand
alors TR cafés gourmand c'est un concert
qui se déroulera le 20 octobre à 20h30 à
la
[Musique]
ferme alors est-ce que ça vous a
convaincu Gabri d'aller voir les trois
cafés gourmands bah oui en plus c'est un
des derniers concerts on l'a compris qui
se passe à côté donc oui pourquoi pas il
a donné deux raisons sur trois qui me
plaisent beaucoup Goldman j'adore je
Goldman et puis passer une bonne soirée
après le festival de Buc pourquoi pas
ouais et puis on a toujours cette
musique qui revient en tête qui nous
fait toujours passer une bonne soirée je
vous propose de poursuivre cette page
culture par une exposition jusqu'au 20
octobre l'espace Alphonse d'udé à
coanière accueille une exposition du
musée Abbé Pierre sur les caricatures de
ce dernier dans la presse cette
exposition s'inscrit dans un projet
d'envergure pour la commune sensibiliser
tous les publics aux valeurs de l'abbé
Pierre reconnu comme défenseur des plus
démunis l'abbé Pierre était sans cesse à
la recherche de justice et de paix c'est
pourquoi la ville de coignère a décidé
de lui rendre hommage on est en
recherche d'un sujet qui amène à parler
de valeurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté d'ailleurs notamment les
valeurs de solidarité les valeurs
d'ouvert vers l'autre et on a trouvé que
la baé pierre était une belle figure et
la plupart d'entre nous l'avaient connu
et donc cette belle figure on s'est dit
elle incarne ses valeurs et pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas faire à coignère une année
à baperre dans cette lignée l'espace
Alphonse d'udé accueille jusqu'au 20
octobre une exposition du musée
Abbé-Pierre sur les caricatures de ce
dernier dans la presse ces quatre
séquences s'articulent autour ben des
des étapes fortes de la baie pierre
notamment les années 50 avec l'appel de
l'hiver 5
en 1954 l'Abbé Pierre publie une lettre
ouverte dans le Figaro où il raconte
comment un bébé est mort de froid dans
la nuit dans un contexte où le
gouvernement refusait d'accorder de
l'argent pour loger les sansabriis puis
les caricatures dans la presse étrangère
ensuite les caricatures de l'abbé Pierre
dans les années 80 90 et donc ensuite
les années 2012 et l'année abépierre se
poursuit à coignère mardi 10 octobre la
ville organise un cinédbat à l'espace
Alfonse d'dé autour du film I feel good
le directeur du musée Abé piierre de
l'association Solidarité nouvelle pour
le logement des yelines et le président
d'maus trap répondront aux questions des
spectateurs c'est un projet musical
jamais vu dans les Evelin bom pour
banlieu wouest mafia réunit près de 50
rappeurs du département des grands noms
comme La Fouine Bosch ou encore 47
terres mais aussi des nouveaux talents
la compilation qui vient de paraître est
un véritable cri d'appartte au
territoire yvelinois et souhaite porter
un message d'apaisement entre les
quartiers c'est le reportage de Grégory
[Musique]
canalé après Marseille et le 93 les
Yvelines aussi ont leur compilation rap
son nom banlieu West mafia près de 50
artistes originaires des quatre coins du
département ont répondu à l'appel de
chabodo depuis 2020 le trapiste a mené
ce projet qui se veut rassembleur entre
les quartiers il a tourné dans tous les
quartiers et surtout du 78 il a senti
que il y avait un besoin d'être tous
réunis avec tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers il
fallait envoyer un message positif et
aujourd'hui bon leest mafia c'est ce
message positif qu'ils envoient la
fouine Bos ou encore le collectif 47
terres des noms connus du grand public
posuse sur la compilation certains
artistes n'ont pas hésité même à sortir
de leur retraite pour se joindre au
projet c'est le cas de trésor membre du
duo l'escadriille dans les années 2000
tout bon rappeur il se doit de
représenter son département si tu le
fais pas et on t'appelle pas à le faire
c'est que tu as des manquements dans ta
technique et peut-être dans ton histoire
j'ai la chance d'avoir tout ça et donc
je le mets à à au bénéfice de mes petits
frères mettre en lumière les jeunes
talents des evelines c'est l'une des
autres ambitions de banlieu wouest mafia
7 c'est la famille donne la force et on
vient montrer ce qu'on sait faire
surtout aussi il y en a pas de comme moi
je vais apporter ma touche mon charisme
rester concentré et j'apporte ma folie
c'est moi tu me parles de musique on va
rapper on va faire les trucs donc moi il
y a pas de complexe viens rap il y a pas
de souci ça depuis que j'ai 10 ans de
toute façon je suis né pour ça donc
autant le vivre à 200 % la compilation a
même rassemblé au-delà des evelines le
DJ talk bxer etolte my a collaboré sur
78 West Side un morceau à la sauce
rapold school c un peu junk voilà c'est
ma cam on va dire tout ce qui est West C
donc j'ai fait pourquoi pas envoie le
son on va regarder ça en plus dessus à
la fouine voilà c'est des légendes 47
chabo
[Applaudissements]
magnifique
bom compte en tout 18 morceaux la
compilation est disponible en physique
et sur toutes les
plateformes alors vous en pensez quoi
John colémaly Gabriel Gontier de cette
nouvelle compilation je trouve que c'est
intéressant de pouvoir
réunir les gens ensemble participer
faire une activité et il y en a vraiment
besoin aujourd'hui et c'est une
initiative intéressante de ce point de
vue bah surtout qu'on parle souvent de
la concurrence dans le rap mais comme
quoi il y a aussi de l'Union donc donc
c'est intéressant et puis il y a des
rappeurs qu'on connaît bien d'autres un
peu moins c'est l'occasion de les
découvrir exactement ça permet de
découvrir de de nouveaux talents c'est
bientôt l'heure de l'invité du 78 mais
juste avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions avoir
un temps et des températures un peu plus
automnales il fera 10°gr à Oudan
Versailles et rambouillé et 11°gr à
Mantel jolie durant l'après-midi le
temps reste stable nous devrions avoir
de belles éclaircis au niveau des
températures ça grimpe légèrement il
fera 17°gr à rambouiller et 18 à Oudan
Versailles et Mantel jolie et demain
nous fêterons la Saint-François c'est
l'heure à présente de passer à l'invité
du
[Musique]
alors avis aux fans de la bonne dessinée
le festival de la BD de Buc c'est ce
weekend pour en parler avec nous John
cémalé je le rappelle vous êtes le Maur
adjoint délégué à la communication pour
la ville de Buc tout à l'heure vous nous
disiez à quel point c'était un
rendez-vous important pour la ville et
donc c'est la 30e édition la 30e année
est-ce qu'il y a une programmation un
peu spéciale pour cette 30e édition
oui une programmation avec beaucoup
d'auteurs beaucoup d'auteurs qui
viennent du monde entier plus de 50
auteurs 53 précisément qui viennent de
du monde entier pas uniquement de
l'Europe mais partout et euh beaucoup
d'activités également
organisé qui ont démarré avant même le
le Festival festival c'est pas que ce
weekend il est présenté dans beaucoup de
villes du département euh et on a eu ça
s'étend sur versailles- grand parc ça
s'étend sur Versailles Grand Parc et
même au-delà parce que nous allons par
exemple dans les épades jusqu'à
rambouiller pour rencontrer les
personnes senior par exemple pour
personnes de public empêché
donc de ce point de vue le le festival a
une vertu aussi pédagogique parce qu'on
on se déplace on va dans les écoles on
rencontre les jeunes on rencontre des
public différents l'objectif c'est de
fédérer autour de la bonne dessinée
l'objectif c'est de rencontrer c'est
vraiment le et c'est la marque de
fabrique de ce festival de Buc c'est la
rencontre conviviale et et ça c'est
vraiment à Buc et à ce festival que que
que nous souhaitons le préserver cette
cette spécificité de ce festival donc on
est on a organisé par exemple également
des beaucoup de séances de dédicac dans
dans des librairies dans les dans les
villes aux alentours de de versaill
grand parc nous avons fait également des
expositions de de bandes dessiné dans
dans les dans les différentes écoles
collèges lycées des environs Gabriel
vous l'avez dit vous allez vers les plus
jeunes comme vers les plus âgés comment
vous expliquez que la BD ça reste un
indémodable ça ça perdure dans le temps
en fait alors aujourd'hui nous avons des
auteurs qui s'adressent à des publics
plutôt jeunes mais nous avons également
des auteurs qui font participer des
public plus âgé euh par exemple moi j'ai
vu quand nous nous sommes déplacés dans
des dans des épades les auteurs aident
euh le public à participer à dessiner
c'est aussi un moyen pour eux de de
s'évader
donc ils ont un rôle à jouer et nous
avons réalisé des albums avec des ce
public et ça c'est c'est c'est
fantastique quand on arrive à
impliquer des personnes qui se
découvrent tout d'un coup des talents
donc et ça c'est c'est vraiment
formidable alors on a vu l'affiche de
cette 20 édition elle met à l'honneur
les schtroumps pourquoi alors la fiche a
été signée par Laurent Cagen qui est un
auteur que qui est très connu qui a
produit plus beaucoup d'albums autour
des des schtroupf il a accepté de de
réaliser notre affiche cette année et
c'était l'occasion de de mettre à
l'honneur le le personnage des des
schtroupes et alors vous avez aussi
prévu tout un tas d'animations il va
avoir un ESC game un escape game une
fresque participative également un spot
manga show est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un peu tout ça voilà donc le
spot c'est la Maison des Jeunes buuc et
nous avons
voulu impliquer le les jeunes de 11 à 25
ans et dans le cadre de ce festival il y
a un escape game autour de de de ce
thème qui va être
organisé au spot il est également prévu
nous avons prévu une bande dessinée
spéciale pour les 30 ans d'accord qui va
être c'est quoi cette bande qui va être
réalisé alors c'est c'est un petit peu
la surprise qui va être dévoilé le le
jour par un auteur
buoir également un personnage qui est
destiné à devenir un peu la mascotte du
du festival et qui sera dorén avant qui
ira partout quand on aura d'autres
d'autres festivals à venir mais qui va
être également la la mascotte de de
festival
et donc voilà donc tout t t tous ces
événements je peux pas tout vous dire
tout vous dévoiler on va garder un peu
de surprise également pour pour ce
weekend pour le public qui viendra alors
on l'a compris il y a beaucoup de choses
vous disiez notamment qu'il y a des des
auteurs du monde entier c'est une fierté
d'avoir ce rendez-vous dans les ivelines
pour vous
oui clairement oui parce que on le voit
d'année en année le public vient en
masse et si vous venez à Buc desè
vendredi vous verrez que les gens campé
déjà et attendre devant le château de bu
dans les dans les visiteurs il y a
également des gens qui viennent de
partout c'est pas que des ivelinois hein
c'est pas que des ivelinois les gens ils
viennent en bus et ils attendent et et
ça c'est c'est c'est vraiment
fantastique le festival commence à être
connu au-delà de nos frontières auà bien
évidemment au-delà de du département
mais mais le festival est vraiment
maintenant connu et encore une fois je
le répète ce qui est très important
c'est ça demeure à taille humaine 10000
personnes mais euh nous privilégions la
rencontre des auteurs et du public vous
avez le temps d'échanger avec un auteur
vous avez le temps de d'aller vous faire
dédicacer votre votre album et et
vraiment vous êtes très proche et c'est
la rencontre conviviale la spécificité
de ce festival de bu et alors parmi
cette cinquantaine d'auteurs quels
seront les grands noms qui viendront qui
se déplaceront ce weekend alors cette
année je neai pas mentionné nous avons
aussi la la chance de fêter les 30 ans
d'un partenariat avec une ville
allemande batcheval bar nous avons
invité des auteurs allemands à à nous
rejoindre à venir cette année à Buc donc
là vous aurez des auteurs de de bande
décidé allemands qui viennent et
également les noms qui sont qui sont
connus hein
comme l'auteur de pzi
[Musique]
Thierry Thierry pedozi oui qui qui qui
sera là vous avez Nicolas qui sera
là Sébastien Vastra donc ce sont des
auteurs connus qui viennent de temps à
autre à Buc et qui reviendront à nouveau
et il y aura quelques avant-premières
également ce weekend j'ai cru entendre
dire que certains auteurs viendront
présenter pour la première fois leur BD
certains auteurs vont venir également
présenter pour la première fois la BD
donc ça forme partie des petites
surprises que nous avons réservé pour ce
weekend vous avez une BD préférée
vous j'aime bien quand j'étais enfant
j'aimais bien les béets de pzi et habite
en Buc maintenant et cette
auteur quand il vient on j'ai sympathisé
avec lui depuis quelques années
maintenant et je suis ravi et il nous a
fait il nous fait l'honneur de faire une
BD qui va nous présenter en
avant-première également et bien merci
beaucoup John coléalet d'avoir répondu à
toutes nos questions je vous attends à
Buc ce weekend et moi je vous souhaite
un bon festival de la BD alors si vous
êtes intéressé c'est ce weekend de 10h à
18 au château de Buc l'entrée est
gratuite et c'est la fin de ce 78 merci
pour votre fidélité vous retrouverez
demain à la présentation Grégory canalé
pour une nouvelle édition je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur tv78
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous